Hello Freak bitches.
Well,
why would I put my job on the line to have an opinion about compelled pronouns?
I know why.
Because the ability to speak your truth is the bulwark against hell
and losing your job.
That's nothing cuts,
nothing compared to where things can go when they go badly.
For me,
it was just preventative.
It's like this isn't going in a good direction.
While should you take a risk?
It's like you don't have that choice.
You're silent.
That's a risk.
Now,
most people don't understand the risks of silence.
I happened to understand the risks of scientists because I've been studying them
for 40 years.
Is it frustrating for you to get so little support for these actions and for,
for your,
your protests?
Well,
I wouldn't say that that's what happened and I don't mean so little support
because you get a lot of support outside of the,
in the outside of the university.
It's okay.
It doesn't matter where the support comes from.
Like I mean it's,
it's disappointing in the same way that it's disappointing for me to say.
I think the universities now do more harm than good.
That's disappointing.
But,
but it,
it doesn't,
it's not surprising to me.
It isn't as if intellectuals are characterized by an intrinsic moral
superiority.
Oh,
they're smart.
So they will leap to the defense of what's right.
It's like,
no,
there's no evidence for that.
And Intelligence and,
and moral wisdom aren't the same thing.
Like,
and if you're corrupt and smart,
all that makes you is way more treacherous.
It doesn't make you less likely to be corrupt.
It just makes you much more,
you're 50 snakes instead of two or your 56 headed snakes instead of to,
like,
I've had clients who were,
who had very serious personality disorders who are very intelligent.
It's like that's not necessarily a good thing for them.
They're just better at arguing for their pathology to themselves.
That is a real problem where people automatically assume that intelligent people
are going to be healthy.
Yeah.
Well they're healthy in that often psychological,
better in the world,
you know,
because their skills are skills are more marketable and so on.
But there's no evidence that there's any relationship between intelligence and
morality.
I mean,
God,
let me tell you a story,
man.
One time I have this client,
this woman was just ruined.
She looked like a street person,
you know,
and she had very dirty clothes and she was so shy that she couldn't even
approach you.
She had to shield her eyes from you as if you were emitting light.
And she did that to everyone on the street.
Like she was banned over and,
and,
and humble like a,
like a Chinese peasant brought before the emperor,
you know.
And,
uh,
one of the things I was doing with her and behavior therapy was trying to just
get her to present herself in a more normal manner so that people wouldn't shy
away from her and,
you know,
be instantly prejudice towards,
and,
and she'd come to the behavior therapy clinic and she wasn't bright.
This woman,
she thinks she had only had like a seventh grade education.
She was quite intellectually impaired and she lived with her,
her sick aunt,
who was,
who was schizophrenia and who had like a,
uh,
say titanic possessed alcoholic boyfriend that was always tormenting my client.
She lived in absolute hell,
but she had this dog and she used to take it out and walk the dog all the time.
And then she,
she'd actually come to the behavior therapy clinic partly because of her own
problem,
but,
but she'd come to this place called the Douglas Hospital and she'd been an
inpatient in the Douglas Hospital and in the,
in the Douglas Hospital,
there were these long term psychiatric clients and they looked like something
out of a Hieronymus Bosch painting or Dante's inferno.
I mean,
these people were,
this is way worse than one flew over the cuckoo's nest.
These people were seriously destroyed and they couldn't be let back out in the
streets during deinstitutionalization.
Like they were lifers.
And she had decided that part of the reason she wanted to come to the
hospitalist because she had been institutionalized there and she thought that
maybe when she took her dog out for a walk,
she could go and get one of those damn inmates and take them out for a walk too.
Now that was a person who was moral,
dumb as a post,
just screwed in 50 different directions.
Nothing going for her.
And she had the bloody moral capacity to decide that there was someone worse off
than her.
And believe me,
that wasn't easy to find.
And that maybe she could do them some good if,
if the hospital would let her,
which they didn't by the way.
Yeah.
Well that's the story of the soul.
That's not the intellect,
that's for sure.
So,
so I didn't expect any support from my,
from my colleagues.
And,
and it isn't that,
I don't care if I got it,
but it's a,
it's in some sense it's irrelevant.
It's irrelevant to me because my goal was,
I'm not saying those goddamn pronouns.
And the reason I'm not saying them is because they're made up by leftwing
ideologues and I don't like left wing ideology.
I don't like ediology period.
And I know where
corruption of speech leads and I'm not going there.
And you know,
one of the things I tried to learn when I was taking apart what happened in
Auschwitz and trying to put myself in the position of an Auschwitz camp guard,
which by the way,
you can do,
if you use your imagination a bit,
I wouldn't call it exactly the world's most pleasant meditative experience,
but you can call up parts of yourself that would be capable of taking someone
who just got off a transport train and having them carry a hundred pound sack of
wet salt from one side of the camp compound to the other and back.
You can conjure that part of yourself up if you want,
and that'll teach you something about what you're like.
People don't do it because it's too frightening,
but I know perfectly well I could do that sort of thing.
And so once I learned that I could do that sort of thing and maybe that I could
even enjoy it,
I thought,
okay,
fine,
I get it.
I'm going to see if I can figure out how to live so that if that opportunity was
presented to me,
I wouldn't take it.
And I think that's the lesson that people need to learn from the 20th century.
It's like that's what human beings did.
Okay.
While we're all human.
Okay,
so how is it that we should live so that we don't do that again?
Well
part of that is to try to say the truth no matter what because the alternative
is worse and it is worse.
The truth no matter what.
And that is the real problem that you see with being forced into using these
made up pronouns.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's my language all take responsibility for what I say.
I am not saying your words and being compelled to say your words by law.
Well that's that.
That that makes it,
that that takes it past the point of absurdity to the point of tyranny in,
in my estimation.
And I've seen some criticisms where people are saying,
you know he's talking about this,
but really he's grandstanding cause no one's doing anything legally,
but the potential exists that such rubbish.
But that is criminals.
Yes.
They wouldn't have changed the damn criminal.
They put it in the hate speech category and altered the criminal code.
It's as simple as that and then you could say,
well no,
we didn't really mean it.
It's like,
Oh yeah you did.
You really meant it to have the social justice warriors that have debated being
the last two months accused me directly of hate speech.
All I had to do was poke them a tiny bit and they came right out with it.
And then the university's legal team reviewed everything I said carefully
believe me.
And they decided that,
oh,
it was not only illegal to not use these compelled pronouns,
it was probably illegal to make a video saying that I wouldn't use them because
otherwise why would they write me a warning letter and tell me that I violated
university policy on the Ontario Human Rights Act?
He did that lightly.
Have they acted on this at all?
Is there,
they won't know.
Well they've acted in that.
They sent me two warning letters and told me to stop talking and the don't.
The idea that I was going to be teaching in January again cause I teach all my
undergraduate courses from January to May.
That was on the table.
And I think the only reason that it hasn't happened,
one of the reasons it hasn't happened,
and I'm not attributing nothing but malevolence to the university
administration,
cause obviously it's very complicated and they did agree to host the debate for
example,
but the idea that I wouldn't be teaching in January and still might not be is by
no means
that was a perfectly plausible outcome.
And had this not caused a firestorm,
much of which has emerged in supportive me.
Then I would say there was a 50 50 chance that I would've had my teaching
privileges revoked,
tabbing to other professors.
So the idea that I'm making it,
I like that is a tempest in a teapot.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
fine.
Why did you change the criminal code then?
And why did you put it under the hate speech laws?
Exactly.
So no,
it doesn't wash.
And I did.
And the fundamental proof of that is the university's response because for sure
there are legal team crafted those letters.
You know what was like recalcitrant employee,
you're responsible for them.
Okay.
What do you do with a recalcitrant deployed?
You write them a letter telling them what they're doing wrong and asking him to
stop.
Then if they don't stop,
you write them a second letter that's more strongly worded.
you write them a third letter,
even more strongly worded.
Then you take disciplinary action.
That's like HR 101 that's how you do it.
So,
so here we said at the end of November,
uh,
closing on December,
you're literally a a bit more than a month away and you don't know whether or
not you're teaching your courses in January.
It seems highly probable that I'll be teaching them.
I wouldn't say it's certain,
but if I'm teaching them,
it's because the cost of having me not teach them would now be too high.
It's not because the university believes that what I'm doing is either necessary
or acceptable.
If someone who's listening to this or watching this feels compelled to act out
in your support,
how can they do that?
I think they could do the future authoring exercise
and that that would be the best way to act on your,
I'm dead serious about this.
It's like sort yourself out,
sort yourself out.
You're so you try to figure out the world and the text.
That's the primary objective.
That's your,
that's your most important thing that you can do yourself out.
Sort yourself out and,
and Marshall your arguments and put yourself in order so that when someone
pushes you a little farther than you should go,
you can say no,
and you know what's going on now.
Yep.